twitch streamer atriak has recently
apologized after being caught paying for
deep fake porn of popular female
streamers the controversy has sparked a
ton of reactions as well as a deeper
conversation about AI generated porn and
deep fake porn altogether it's very
complicated issue so we'll try to break
it down
on January 26th atrioch the popular
variety streamer was live on Twitch
playing Hitman during the stream atriak
tabbed out and unknowingly revealed all
of his windows one of those tabs was a
link to a website that had deep fake
pornography of female streamers due to
the illegality of such websites we won't
be naming those who are depicted on the
websites after that viewers uploaded
clips and screenshots of the situation
to social media some pointed out that
the host website works like only fans or
patreon so the content is behind a
Creator's paywall meaning that atrial
must have paid for it on Monday atriak
went live to address the situation this
time he was sitting with his wife and
gave an apology and an explanation I I
don't know I got morbidly curious and I
clicked something and I it's just it's
it's gross it's gross and I'm sorry
atrial continued to explain that over
the years he has been consistently
against the exploitation of female
content creators and has done his best
to create a healthy Community he also
claimed that he had a receipt for the
transaction that would prove he only
ever did this once but decided it would
be inappropriate to show it on stream
later his life Ari spoke agreeing that
there was no evidence that atriarch has
done anything like this in the past it's
deeply upsetting and extremely
embarrassing but I do believe Brandon in
saying this is not a pattern of behavior
in the aftermath a ton of creators came
together to condemn the creation of deep
fake porn and the general non-consensual
sexualization of women on the internet
this includes many female creators who
have been and currently are victims
people can post whatever they want and
that still means that you need their
consent to do certain things including
sexualizing them and then profiting off
of it since atriox last stream the
website and the content on it have been
taken down and that creator has even
issued their own apology writing I feel
like the total piece of [__] that I am
the best course of action I have
understood is to just wipe my part off
the internet and help decrease the
number of future videos of those
involved you will not see me pop up
again atriak also released a twit longer
further apologizing to the people who he
immediately affected and condemning
those who didn't see the issue as a big
deal he also praised the women and Law
Firm who petitioned for this website and
its content to be taken down now there's
a lot of conjecture surrounding the
people that are involved in atriox
situation but it's been made abundantly
clear that this just exposes a much
deeper issue you see the site that's
been removed is likely just a part of a
larger network of websites that produce
this explicit non-consensual pornography
and while there have been pushes to
Outlaw these websites there's far from
illegal consensus on them as Vice and
kataku have reported While most U.S
states have laws against non-consensual
sexual material California Texas and
Virginia are the only states that
currently have specific laws against
deep fakes in California you are
potentially able to sue those who create
and profit off of sexual images of your
likeness and in the case of Virginia
deep faked pornography actually falls
under the revenge porn laws meaning it
can result in a fine and imprisonment of
up to 12 months as Kotaku points out
affected streamers that actually live in
California can potentially sue the
creator of this pornography and it seems
that one streamer is doing just that the
UK is currently in the process of
passing laws to help protect people from
the this form of online exploitation but
as far as the rest of the US Canada and
much of the world there is still a lot
that needs to be done to protect
people's identities unfortunately this
is the case for a lot of things that are
supposed to protect women's bodies as it
stands if someone is affected by Deep
fake content of themselves they are
forced to manually remove it themselves
or pay for a team to do it for them this
situation has sparked a much bigger
conversation about AI generation deep
fakes and someone's right to their own
image and privacy it's a long overdue
conversation but one that's likely just
begun
thank you
foreign